Captain has turned on the fasten seat belt sign.
We do ask all our passengers, take your seat at this time and please fasten your seat belt.
Just as a reminder, we cannot leave the gate until carry-ons are properly put away,...
...all overhead bins are closed and all passengers are seated.
To those passengers who are seated in one of our designated exit rows,...
...you may be called upon to open that exit in the event of an emergency.
We do ask that you take a moment to locate the safety briefing card...
...located in the seat back pocket in front of you.
Should you feel you're unable in any way to open an exit,...
...please contact the flight staff this time and we will reseat you.
Forward boarding door has been closed.
Once again, we do need all passengers to remain seated at this time.
Please double-check the security of your seat belt.
All electronic devices do need to be turned off and put away this time.
This does include all cellular phones and two-way pagers.
Flight attendants, please prepare doors for departure, cross-check.